prince william and kate middleton
getting their kids back to school ready
prince george princess charlotte and
prince louis visit the lambrook school
in the uk
check out the duke and duchess of
cambridge holding hands with their
little ones attending an event welcoming
new students ahead of the first day of
school
i teach children yeah you're looking
forward to looking forward to all
yeah the royal family is as regal as
ever george and louie twinned in
checkered button-down shirts blue shorts
and black shoes while charlotte matches
her brothers in a blue dress
they also stop to chat with the
headmaster before checking out their new
school
welcome george welcome to library hey
louie welcome and welcome charlotte
lovely to have you with us the change in
schools comes as william and kate
relocate the family say goodbye to
kensington palace and moving to a new
home in the county of berkshire
the outing also follows a milestone for
princess charlotte last month the
seven-year-old royal attended the
commonwealth games with mom and dad
marking her first time stepping out
without her siblings the family watched
a hockey match between england and india
and birmingham and charlotte clearly had
a few questions for her parents that's
when the funny faces began
yeah we're pretty sure the young
princess won't have a problem making
friends at our new school
[Music]
you